[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Maggie's
in Atlanta hi Maggie welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey Dave thanks so much for taking
my call sure what's
up hey so I'm just calling today I've
been listening for about two to three
months now um I'm 20 years old I've been
doing an every dollar budget uh for
about a month now and I am needing to
get my own place um and in I mean ASAP
and I don't even know the first place to
start preparing for it um my income is
fairly low and my monthly bills are
pretty high so I just wanted to call in
and and what is your advice my income is
um 2,300 monthly what do you
do um I process medical records right
now okay and you're 20 years old yes sir
20 and I only have a high school a high
school diploma okay are you looking for
new work CU your income
sucks yeah yeah it it does um I I I've
been looking around to see what I can do
um but with no no degree and no degree
is not a hold back at all yeah I I live
in rural Tennessee I saw a sign the
other day that said McDonald said $20 an
hour yeah I do I am I do have a side
hustle that I am starting um after the
holidays are over I'm starting a side
hustle and that'll be like $15 an hour
but that's only the weekend that I can
do a side hustle because my job now is a
9 to5 so what what happens after
five after five after five is when you
work from 5:00 a.m. to 9:00 a.m when
you're broke that's when you
work yeah um I do have a well I kind of
have a one-year-old my boyfriend um has
a Oney kind of Oney old that's
impossible that that's imp that's that's
physically impossible you do it's not
your baby you're
saying yes your boyfriend has a
one-year-old yeah well that's not I'm
sorry baby you're broke you're not
you're not babysitting your boyfriend's
kid when you're broke and you got to get
a place to live and you don't have you
don't have the money
right I don't think I have the money to
no no um right now I'm living with my
sister um I've been out on my own since
I was like 17 18 I've been living in
people's rooms and just renting rooms
and now I kind of want a place for just
me and my boyfriend and his son no no no
no no no no no no no no you you're not
in a position to be taken care of
people no no no If he if he wants to get
married and take care of you we'll talk
about it what does he
make he's not working right now oh this
is real good Maggie Maggie are you hear
yourself out loud firefighter yes sir
yeah yes sir if you were if you if you
were talking to your daughter and your
daughter was you you'd smack
her well I wish my mama would have yeah
I know but I mean you you listen to
yourself I'm going to move in with a guy
who has a one-year-old and doesn't work
and I have to take care of the kids and
I'm supposed to take care of these
people I I think you need to go
somewhere where there's
grown-ups he's he why he's not working
right now is he's he's becoming a
firefighter so he that doesn't start
until the beginning of January though so
right now he's just waiting to see so
right now he's not in school to be a
firefighter he's only waiting for which
Firehouse he's going to be doing so why
is he sitting on his butt during
Christmas yeah yeah it's a good question
he should be he should be driving for
Uber from 5 to 8 5:00 a.m. to 8: a.m.
you want to date my daughter you work
and then work all day and then
delivering pizzas at night cuz that's
that's what men do when they don't have
a job and they have a
one-year-old yeah yeah and he hasn't he
hasn't worked for about like eight
months now I can almost guarantee you I
can almost guarantee you he's not going
to the fire academy you know how I know
firemen don't live like
that that's not the character of a
fireman I know those men and those women
they have they have they work their fire
shifts and then they have another job
and they have another job on top of that
you know why because they are so
invested and working and going out and
serving their
communities I can almost guarantee you
he won't go to the fire academy no he's
already gone hadn't
he well he's waiting to hear back he
hasn't started yet no Dave he's he
hasn't even started the fire academy yet
he hasn't worked for eight months that
oh I thought he just finished he was
waiting to get assigned a job hold on he
has a one-year-old how's he not worked
for eight months have you supported
him
yeah his mom his mom does a lot and then
Magie H Maggie please talk listen to two
old farts okay both of us have daughters
run run as fast as you can run oh no yes
oh yes I don't think I can do that okay
I'm sorry I can't help you darling
you're running blind into the wall and
you're going you're going you're going
to blow the car up when you hit it oh
I'm sorry honey you you've been a
Survivor you bounced from room to room
you left home at 17 years old your mama
didn't tell you not to do this stuff two
guys who love you and love our daughters
are telling you if you were our daughter
we would get rid of Mr fireman he he
would just disappear somewhere we
wouldn't be able to find him you're
being prayed upon sweetheart I'm telling
you this is not going to happen all
right and so uh you need an ugly angry
older brother or father like one of us
and we would tell him to go away and if
he didn't we'd help you go away cuz you
got the stuff to go get it done in the
marketplace girl you can go out there
get you three jobs get you an apartment
start you a life start taking a degree
field I'll send you a copy of Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
you can start working on your career
you're sharp talking to you but your
judge of men is
sucks and when you have a man with a
one-year-old who's responsible he
doesn't work for eight months we call
that a dead beat a
burnout and if you ever listen to me
talk or listen to my show I'm overly
compassionate and I've got zero
compassion for a man who's got a toddler
who let a 20-year-old girl living in a
her sister's house take care of them
zero none z0 Z you have a daughter you
have a
child yeah my goodness I I I I please
Maggie he should be ashamed of himself
man but but you're you're not going to
do it and you're going to learn the hard
way and you're going to call me up at 25
and you're going to go yeah you were
right and now I've got all this debt cuz
I went and bought him a car and um and
we rented an apartment and he didn't pay
the bill and the landlord threw us out
and I've got got a judgment lean from
the landlord and you're going to be that
caller if you go f through with this
please do not go move in with this guy
if you don't dump him that's your
business uh I think you're on the way to
dumping him you should be but it but for
sure for God's sake quit giving him
money and don't move in with him so and
let's say this so for those of you who
have grown up the last five or six years
you like Maggie you're on your own
you're bouncing from room to room to
room and you spend a lot of time on
social media it appears that things just
happen it appears that bills just get
paid and what you're finding out is oh I
only make
$2,300 but I have a an inside job in a
medical community um and it feels like
I'm connected to something bigger and
I'm not working at McDonald's for God's
sakes or I'm not going to throw boxes at
Walmart I would never do that and you're
going to realize that things don't just
happen you have to make enough money
it's a math problem to make enough money
to pay for your rent and for your water
and for your food and for your
electricity and for your car all all
these things are very expensive which
means you got to go get one job you got
to get two jobs you got to get three
jobs develop a plan that is a career
where you don't have to work 80 hours a
week there you go but it takes a few
years to get into
that but most of us um that are older
than 30 have worked more than 40 hours
like more than 80 hours the first five
years of our working life or 10 of our
life um or more yeah and so um and and
that's not a you're you're you have no
life balance no I have a life that you
wish you freaking had I can tell you
that you just wish you had a tenth of my
life but I work my tail end off to get
here that was a good self sensor Dave I
got that you got it just right there
right there right create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life